[Music]
hey
what are you guys doing out here it's
halloween we've been trick-or-treating
we got a whole bag you guys should not
be out here right now okay it's not safe
you're gonna kill me
satan not today oh i'm so scared are you
guys alone where are your parents no no
we're waiting for our friend and like
there's a creepy man in a white mask and
he keeps like trying to play hide and
seek with us
where did you see him he's just hiding
behind trees and he pops out like
peekaboo i mean we're not three years
old come on man oh look there he is oh
hello
hello
[Music]
is that dennis's mask
run go home now before he kills us all
get out of here run do not turn around
hey
what are you guys doing out here it's
halloween we've been trick-or-treating
are you alone there's a creepy man in a
white mask
where
and he keeps like trying to play
hide-and-seek with us where did you see
him
[Applause]
[Music]
my grandmother set the fire
no one told you
tell me what
michael myers is alive
a man couldn't have survived that fire
40 years ago the boogeyman came for us
we are the survivors of michael myers
lori what do we do we fight
mom or family we'll kill him we're gonna
hunt him down and we're gonna put an end
to this
he is not gonna stop killing until we
stop him
if you track michael's victims that's a
straight line
to michael's childhood home
someone's in our house
he's coming for me
but i'm coming for him
you want to kill someone take me
like i want to take his mask off and see
the life of leave his eyes
[Music]
foreign